sérieux le guignol là depuis thaler
savez maintenant tu as un singe
carrément ce soutien il ya plus de
twitter l'a relaté en vérité dans la
vraie vie mais pas plus qu'ailleurs
parce que alors je vous explique je me
suis embrouillé avec deux rappeurs hier
sur twitter à ses piques flo et oli qui
est big lots qui relie c'est moi avec
flo et toi y'a pas twitter c'est devenu
mon nom mais je vais vous expliquer ça
va se calmer parce qu'on s'est un petit
peu clasher sur twitter tu fais beaucoup
le malin sur internet mais en vrai je
sais pas ce que ça donne vraiment envie
de ça et après ça y'a plus les
téléphones ya plus rien la haye ouais
mais pourquoi c'est quoi ça chauffe
croyez vous aller me cacher on a monté
une marque 1 c'est quoi ces anti hanouna
en asie aspetar contre moi là c'est nous
deux va voir mon pote pas se régler
ok les deux on a une bouteille alors et
vous c'est quoi être très bonnes
résolutions c'est quelque chose d'assez
personnel et intime c'est je vais
essayer de moins montrer mon zizi dans
les loges parce que c'est vrai que je le
fais on essaie de se décontracter avant
l'émission j'ai tendance à montrer un
peu trop souvent
au début je crois que ça faisait rigoler
les gens et je me suis rendu compte
c'est donc ca complexe et certains
coûtent banon
[Musique]
hier cyril on s'occupe de toi ok le
requin déguisant sardines à voir à temps
mais que j'ai trop faim depuis qu'on est
dans public à je vais prendre un kebab
ressemblance avec des frites et non tu
trompes c'est pas le vendeur de kebabs
mais c'est le présentateur c'est lui
l'arnaqué syrie le plus grand des
acteurs mais les pas perdre tu feras pas
grand chose j'te ferai pas de flair même
site à la tête d'un vendeur de roses
radio twitter télé était partout c'est
fatigant pour faire que ça tu engagé
quoi un sosie du pakistan tu fais de la
télé alors t'es pas présentables
tellement voix lui que les rasoirs se
cassait sa barbe il se prend pour une
star depuis qu'il fait du cinéma il a
joué dans le dernier star wars chewbacca
nouna trop de maquillage
vous êtes tous orange ou jaune mon petit
cousin fans ils pensent qu'ils regardent
les simpson maintenant franchement c'est
trop tard et franchement gros tas - de
quick et nora rapide meesseman il n'est
jamais dans la dèche l'été gray a perfé
pmp il vend des babouches à marrakech
nous fait croire que tu es comme nous
mais ça me fatigue
j'te jure dans l'hôtel cinq étoiles
juste en face de notre camping et on va
attaquer n'est pas qu'on évitait les
ballons des parcs ont extrait les
mâconnais clan des barrages avec un de
ses rares lannelongue eu le courage de
maïs non fédrigo
arrête parce que comme tout le monde en
garde les missions le soir en cachette
mais on est des mythos est parce qu on
est juste des poteaux mais personne ne
croit chez nos scieries l'on peut
prendre une photo et laura que les
bonnes résolutions pour 2016 faire
l'amour avec cinq fruits et légumes par
jour
fruit de galié la santé le sexe
macédoine a oui mais il faut que vous
alliez voir d d d d d aubergines c'est
bon c'est bon et jean luc lemoine
maintenant j'ai pas dû j'ai vu des onze
mille verges en comédie musicale avec le
lignon les onze mille verges en
apprendre des vertes et des pas mûres
c'est obligatoire
ils sont